Hello and welcome to the next video on the interface.
This time we're going to look at how you can manipulate
and move actors around a scene.
Okay, so we're back in the editor now.
And before we start moving actors around,
let's add in a primitive or a shape
that we can see it slightly better on.
I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna come up to the add, the quickly add to project.
I'm gonna come down and I will search for shapes.
I'm gonna select the cube.
That's gonna create a cube in front of me here.
And I'll focus on that cube.
Bye, so we have a cube.
Now, you probably don't see this widget if you just come in
and that's because you'd be in selection mode.
If you look around, move stuff around,
you can see that in selection mode, there are no widgets,
but we do have a clear frame in order to select things.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna come up
to the top left-hand corner here.
And you can see in this,
we have a blue highlighted select object.
And next to it, we have another three options.
So if I select the second one, which is translate,
you'll now be able to see that we get this widget
with these three axes pins.
And if you'd notice down in the details panel,
we have a location here.
And if I was to move the location,
it's going to change the location of the object.
Also, if I was to change the rotation,
it's gonna change the rotation too.
And scale, I'll be able to scale it up and down
on different axes.
And that is not the easiest way to do this.
It's far easier to do it within the editor itself
in the viewport.
So in translation mode,
you can see that I can now move the actor
on any one of the specific axes.
And if I was to come in closer,
you can see that I have a square between two of the axes.
And all this would do is you'll only move it
on the two selected axes.
So I'm left clicking and dragging it around.
And this is useful if you want to sort of move something
on the wall or on the floor.
You also select the center,
which is gonna move it,
it's slightly consistent with the camera itself.
I don't use that very much.
But that is the translate mode.
It's gonna allow us to move the location
of the actor itself.
Next up, we have the rotate.
And this is gonna give us a slightly different widget.
It's going to give us a widget still with three axes.
It's gonna allow us to move it
on any of these specific axes.
Now it's to rotate it in space accordingly.
There's not the option to select two axes within this.
Turn it to normal.
Final one is scale.
And again, with scale,
we can just select one of the specific axes, X, Y, Z.
Or we can select two by going on the triangle in the middle
that allow us to scale on the lock one of the axes.
Or we can select the middle,
which will allow us to uniformly scale the whole thing.
Now, we've manually clicked on the different
select object elements here.
However, that is not necessary
because we have them on hotkeys.
And the hotkeys will be the first four buttons
in the top left-hand corner of a QWERTY keyboard.
So Q is selection mode, W is translate,
E is rotate and R is scale.
So you can quickly slip between these
by just clicking on the buttons.
So just to reiterate there,
in order to move them around,
the Q will give us the just select object,
W will give us the translate,
E will give us the rotate and R would give us the rotate.
And R would give us the scale.
Next up, let's have a look at these three buttons on top.
You may have noticed, as I've been moving things,
it's very hard to see,
that they are moving in increments.
So the moment I have this set of things,
they're snapping in increments.
Increments start off as quite small,
so it's a little bit hard to see,
but if I was to use the drop down here
and select a larger increment,
you'd see that it is snapping in a larger increment.
Now we have three of these,
one for translation, rotation and scale.
And you can see next to each of them,
we have a drop down that determines our increments.
So I would, if I can come into this,
I've set it to 60 increments, so for rotation,
you'd see that it rotates in large increments like this.
And for scale, I'm gonna set it to one,
so if we were to change the scale,
it's going to move up in quite large increments.
Now you might not always want this,
so if you want to turn this off,
you can just click on any of these.
The moment they're highlighted as on,
because they're in blue,
if I was to turn them off, for example,
let's do that on rotation,
now we can freely rotate.
Come that's exactly the same for scale and translation.
So that is snapping.
The increments are below,
you can go into edit to preferences
and change the increments if you specifically need them.
We're talking about translation,
the unreal units are centimeters.
Another hot key that's worth knowing
is if I was to grab this
and press the end key,
that's going to drop it to the ground.
So it just uses the collision to figure out
where things are or drop it to the ground at that point.
Now we have looked at adding actors
to your scene by using the add button
in the top left hand corner.
And in the next video,
we're going to be looking at using the content browser.
However, there is one other method
that I'd like to bring up whilst I'm here.
And that is if you were to hold down the alt P
whilst moving or changing the transform of an object,
rather than changing the translation of the object,
it is going to duplicate the actor itself.
And this tends to be one of the quickest ways
to add an extra actor,
especially if you already have one in scene.
It's a very quick way.
And you can see this will work for Penny or the,
or any of the actors that exist in the scene,
even if they are not static meshes
that we have at this point.
Okay, and that brings us to the end of our interface section
on manipulating actors within the scene.
In the next video,
we're going to look at using the content browser.